hey everyone I'm Lana Gil Eric coming at
you live from the ET suite at Comic Con
with some of these amazing zombie
killers from The Walking Dead
hi guys can we just talk about this
little crossover that we've got going on
right now are you wearing the Black
Panther Clause mess me up for a minute
there are you trying to tell us that
you're gonna be in the next black
panther yeah but like this I'm gonna be
like disco pants just go people you are
comic-con vets by this point what is
your favorite thing about coming to this
and meeting all of the fans in person
mmm I think meeting owns the fans in
person yeah basically no I mean it's
it's every year it's it's great and I
don't know I feel like comic-con is like
our time with the fans it's the fans
time especially with Walking Dead one
thing that really just feels like this
is where we belong with our fans does
that make sense it definitely makes
sense yeah I'm so thrilled that you guys
are all here right now but you know
there are so many rumors that Andrew
Lincoln did not be coming back to the
Walking Dead after the ninth season can
you clear it up for us a little bit okay
yesterday
yeah yeah beautifully of course and how
are you feeling about that you know I
mean he's my BFF forever yeah I'm bummed
Slade a dear brother sitting right here
you can either be out there
but you know I mean he's he's been the
leader of this show and he's definitely
the quarterback of his team he always
will be and his shoes will never be
replaced or no and no one will be
wearing those shoes you guys give us a
first look at Season nine and the
introduction of the
exciting I was excited it was in the
trailer because we didn't know there was
going to be revealed yesterday and we
know like everybody's losing their mind
because people have been waiting for a
long time for a long time but knowing
from the comics that they're coming so
whispers you're badass I mean it's
saying that they're even more badass
than negan well they're definitely I
think screwed-up [ __ ] a bit of a mess
but these guys take it to a whole nother
level mm-hmm whispers so um I think it's
kind of exciting when we last left off
in the season 8 finale
Maggie was clearly upset with the
decision that Rick made to keep negan
alive and it seemed like Daryl
completely agreed with her how are we
gonna see them move forward cuz we
didn't force about that and we had
talked about - and we all made this
decision and then it's like wait a
minute that's how he said that that's
how he did it what was it guilt was
bring him to justice pants well I don't
work makes a lotta bad
back on the show yeah yeah yeah no man
are you saying that you wish that
Jeffrey wasn't sitting next year no I
just like he's a great guy yes I mean
that's not what I was searching for but
okay I mean I'm deeply complicit I'm
gonna hold her back and all right but
behind the scenes
she's like fans are ideal of trying to
evolve past the eye for an eye type of
thing you know and you know he was
trying to honor his son and what his son
had said made sense I can't just keep
killing to kill to kill to kill to kill
right right it's a little blinded by
that passion to fix that problem but
maybe that's what we were dissipated
yeah that's the question yeah well I am
curious to know especially for Michonne
and Rick how do they move forward
knowing that they're hopefully going to
be creating a mini paradise someplace
that made me think babies maybe they
would have a baby one day
well the idea you know that they they
came together to distant and came to
about you know a season and a half ago
is they wanted to reorder the world and
the idea of reordering it was trying to
get it back to a to something functional
something you know that you know you can
build on generationally and have order
and law and you know so the idea that
you sort of come to see them sort of
coming to war
and really coming into a lot of conflict
with is how do you start to create a
constitution again how do you start to
create a charter common laws when folks
are all on their own vendetta's and
they're all you know we're not let's how
do you all get on the same page and how
do you help people get there to a place
where you have a vision for and they
don't have the same vision for and then
you use what do you do de facto say were
the ones who are making the decisions
which kind of happened with Meighan and
there's a lot of byproducts to that so
it's a it's messy but they're trying to
they're really trying to make it better
for everybody
ya know we are trying to make it better
for everybody well and some different
ladies are taking charge and they can
make it a great place to live like cuz I
know that the season nine is gonna
really be about female leadership and
really just seeing these women really
take charge how does that make you feel
as women it makes me feel really
[Music]
relieved would women take god no man
let's talk about Daryl and Carol my
favorite friendship sorry guys what can
you tease that is coming ahead for them
um you know Carol's doing her thing this
way and Daryl's kind of doing this thing
this way but they they have they was
kind of a Romeo and Juliet thing
happening not the way you think but uh
you know those who characters well there
is because this is the third time today
wait tell me what it is whatever that's
interviewing all day oh it's like going
swimmingly
oh yeah see ya don't tell me just like
Romeo and Juliet except for the other
way not the way you think you know this
is great that's the real Romeo engine
yeah people yeah when it happens they're
like oh that's what they that's what
yeah and it's all in what kinda deny
we've known for the past eight years
what a badass Michonne is on the walking
dead and now seeing you kick butt on
screen just really elevating the
performance in black panther in my
opinion what does that been like for you
and you're gonna take any of those
stunts and apply it to Walking Dead
Season nine yeah you know Michonne Okoye
are very separate women like I always
say like you know people to ask me that
and I'd say I think Michonne is more
like Nakia she's more like Nikita's
character you know because she is there
like by whatever means necessary type
chicks you know whereas Okoye is very
traditionalist you know the way she
moves like using the disappearance of
vibranium spirit is still spear that's
traditionalism like she's doing the
things that her mother's mother's
mother's this is designed for how they
they engage in combat you know whereas
you know a queer and I mean we're lakiya
and shown are like what what will work
how what oh how hard the job done quick
efficiently you know streetwise they
have a street style to them so I always
consider them to be interestingly
separate I would never conflate them
because then that that
the paint's their specificity who's
jonesing to get a spot in the next black
panther well Norman that's why yeah yeah
what I do well there's the best tease
that you can give fans can you give
something you didn't talk about on the
panel at all there was that part yeah
you tell em can we see this group find
happiness no well I can tell you we're
gonna see baby this list yes this 14
year pregnancy has come to an end and he
is the sweetest in the room
I did I did actually on the first day
that we worked for them thank you so
much for sitting down with me I really
appreciate it let's go have some fun in
the photo booth thanks for watching fans
five